t-you hearings on civilians
it will be 11 zlotins already overate rule
types of innocent and by the look of the civilian
population of the Russian ards I perfectly
hid that we still have the
same appearance here the primals are actually the price of
Putin’s safari he actually
shot the Ukrainian nation the Ukrainian
people of recalculation  riding breeches who you understand
why they will move simply can’t
I didn’t arrive at eight o’clock in the evening he was
beaten off here with machine guns
then they brought his apartment for the first
search and under a little search they took
me with the dogs my Peking dog and
led us
with our hands upside down to the second floor and this
down there the headquarters was at home
going out for 5 days ten for thirteen
days I have been looking for him and then I go to
this basement the woman went I will declare to the
red cross that my husband disappeared from
such and such a date 20 days I am
already looking for him they yes  they took my data, everything
I come and this is a woman, then don’t go
look, maybe you can bring two corpses there,
only maybe you
will order him, I found out e
my neighbor has
cramps in his sneakers and he has a shot past the head
and from a kind of
blanks
I went to every quest I tell me what to
do so that the dogs from the cliff tell
me I will show you the grave and they
buried him a meter we were
looking for dogs more than once and now  that's all for
now
[applause] the
whole train powerful king will you become the
light I'm genocide more often than you are here today
and and for almost a century there was an axis we
know thousands of people downed because of ready
for a
bucket of bans ken chicks dump wolf
stuffing to be edit and  I think it
’s only
[music]
we can do
it all at 5 and the prosthesis that the
buccal ones will pop out and nations 1 euro ovens the
retinue is sharpened more than once, it’s still covered, so I
don’t distinguish the same option, we are not at home, but the
same kind of weave than
whole steam situations  cuttings
will be overgrown with alliances to live on and I will
drag people to go out for kotova her to case
in a million this all these stories about
thousands let's count the bodysuit wines
will be led we will oh you watched the
most public
actor kim and music we will not be robots of animals pauses to find all the evil de ravine impose to decide then the laureates looked frighteningly u treat does not come out of the fights this is a waffle watering can cookie for a share and you cook of work on the disco with a guru and you have and so formoso caricatures admitting since I’m not fair-haired stitch below the zone, I take credit for naming them by name, that is, well, let them take into account the sun for that rabble of the have-not and cho dream zone I’m contentment for the rabble and a module fancy veles nissan kix to collect let's imagine that you can hear sweet in a thermos 2 shops of cream economy neighbors national organizations he will give out internationals except for typhus that's enough sugar volt don't judge zynga bit dewalt from documenting children then he ira of the keyboard and so he shaft 500 g demanded an urgent work meeting of the security council these days another attack was launched in the city of Bucha, Kyiv region, after Russian servicemen left from there in accordance with
plans
and agreements reached
there, in a few days, I arranged a
staging that is dispersed through all
channels and social networks by Ukrainian
representatives, their Western patrons, I will
tell you that the longer the
Russian Federation delays the
meeting process, the worse it is for and for them and, in
principle, for
this situation for  of this war,
because every day when our troops come in
and yes the Cooper leaves or other territories you
see what is happening very difficult to
talk very difficult to talk
when you see what they have done here
and
every day you understand there are people in
barrels cellars and so on strangled and
just tortured, so I think that
if they have something to think, then think
faster